[оплески]
[музика]
ва чоловіка з синім
юкза Антон там уже всередині Ми одна тут
камера на вулиці будешти
Я тобі буду писать я буду тобі
писать
що сди
пхо
а барикада стояла диких собак не пускала
диких собак не
пускала то бариканта стояла тут собак не
пускала до ких
[музика]
собакскала на щей
бензин горіла шина ще й бензин стріляв
здалека сучий син стріляв з далека суший
син
оілашина ще й бензин стріляв з далека
сучий син стріляв з далека сучий син
поів машина щей
нішох го машина щей
нішок ой нам
тітушокйсли нам
[музика]
тітушокжи на щейнішок ой навесли нам
тітушок ой навесли нам
тітушок оки зеки ви
мої Ой зеки зеки ви мої довго служили ви
мені довго служили би
мені ой зеки яки ви мої довго
служилимені довго
служили більше служить не
будете більше служить не будете під Су
народний підете підсу народний
підете більше служить не будете під суд
народни підете під суд народни дете
під суднародний трибунал
під суднародний трибунал кожен піде
регіонал кожен піде
регіонал суд народний трибунал кожен
піде регіонал кожен піде
регіонал
голаши на
палала гола шина палала Там барикада
стояла Там барикада
стояла орлаши на палала Там барикада
[музика]
стояла
десь високо аж під небом
роздається лютий грім сотнями ідуть
Повстанці боронити
рідний дім
й кому несеє рівно той хто любить і
горить
недалеко за кордоном пліч оплічстой
устої ей у гора бій
гегегей стороні не стій егейгегей Срібна
Земля
ге-гегей твоя вона
ге-гегей угорабій
гегегегей в Стороні нестій
гегегегей Срібна Земля
гегегей твоя
водна
так вже склалось с боком віку в кому
воля Ще жива той нам стане побрати
мондоля в нас на всіх одна гегегей у
гора бій егегегей стороні настійееей
рибна
земля
гегегей воя вода
егегегей у
горахій егегегей в Стороні не стій
гегегегей снихна земля
гегегегей Лія
[музика]
вода Слава Україні
славало
переди
соронітесті егегеей свіна земля
гегегей твоя вона
ей у горах бі
й в Стороні несті
[музика]
сільна земля
ееей твоя вона
гееегей у гора бій гееей скороні не сі
еей срімна земля
ееей твоя вона
егегей у горах бі
гегегей здороні
нестіегегей Срібна Земля
еегей толь я
вона друзі А зараз я хочу запросити вас
привітати людину без якої Петро
Порошенко Не став би таким який він і є
нашим лідером Я хочу щоб ви привітали
справжню першу леді Марину Анатоліївну
[оплески]
Порошенко
Порошенко поро пошенко
Порошенко пороше і ще раз перша лейді
Марина натоліївна
[оплески]
Порошенко Вітаю вас дорогі друзі
Хоча
ні як сказав Юрій
журавиль Вітаю вас дорогі пороха брати і
пороха
[оплески]
сестри подивиться Подивіться скільки нас
багато які ми всі різні і за віком і за
професією і за
уподобаннями але всіх нас об'єднує любов
до України і несприйняття
несправедливості і саме тому сьогодні
тут в
треті раз ми зібралися для того щоби не
[музика]
дати
творити діючи
репресивному режиму
свої чорні справи
ви
подивиться Спочатку вони прийшли до
волонтерів і ветеранів призначивши їх
винними Потім вони почали
відкривати безглузді справи проти
бойових генералів і
політиків вони чинять наступ на наш
Томас А вчора
реваншисти знов атакували нашу
мову і все це вони роблять для того
щоб цими безглузними діями примусити
залікати нас примусити нас мовчати
вичевати з країни для того щоб вже ніхто
не заважав їм повернутися до часів
Януковича і в залізні обійми крмля
так
вони нападають на нас поодинці але вони
бояться нашої
єдності і
тому Агенти Кремля намагаються не тільки
захопити нашу
територію вони впливають на свідомість
наших
громадян для того щоб нав'язати нам
думку що
ми не відбулися як справжня
країна
що ми нібито така
фйлстейт країна
помилка і нинішня Влада їм в цьому
підігрує руйнуєчи державні установи і
призначаючи ворога всередині
країни і тому зрозуміло Чому саме
особистими ворогами для них є волонтер
ветерани і п'ятий президент України
Порошенко тому що справжнім авторитетом
для них є Путін і його
Посіпаки
вони відкривають
ефемерні справи вони розповсюджують
недостовірні соціальні
опитування намагаючись
підмінити правду
брехнею але рано чи пізно люди
зрозуміють де правда а де брехня із є
команда не усвідомлює що саме ця брехня
їх саміх і
погубить а наше завдання
тримати
стрій і берегти рідну
землю тому що ми сильні своєю
правдою і об'єднані любов'ю до України а
сильна
вільна європейська Україна вона варта
цих зусиль вона варта того щоби за неї
боротися і ця
боротьба
обов'язково завершиться
перемогою бо ми сильні В нашої
єдності Слава Україні героям
Слава друзі Хто тільки підійшов Я хочу
вам повідомити новину яку ви можливо не
чули що ще зранку російське інформаційне
агентство повідомило що рішення суду вже
є тобто ще нема
підсудного Хоча я навіть не знаю чи він
його можна так назвати людину яку
звинувачують взагалі
не необосновано російсько щоб вони
розуміли а вони вже опублікували новину
що вже вирок суду є як це може бути На
кого працює тоді цей суд якщо росіяни
вже знають який буде вирок ганьба цьому
суду ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба ганьба
ганьба зараз я хочу щоб ми подивилися Ну
як блогер я і наша команда ми
підготували для вас відео Подивіться
будь
[музика]
[оплески]
ласка
дились ми великої годиницьво жеж війни і
полувябовни
лекав нас бі за долю України ссти в нас
Гнів ідуть на ворогі лева насбі
за долю України зстрів нас Гнів і лютьь
на ворогів
ми
йдемоій переможним ходом ідив сї не злав
ні Бог гранів поплач не дав нікому ще
Свободи
хворець збугає світ полачуу не дав
нікому ще Свободи хто порес той звуває
світ Україну Україну святавати герой
святавати герой і докарзаного п
докарзаного за твою славу за твою славу
за твої святідей за твої святідень нехай
душа моя тобі відродиться нехай душа моя
тобі відродиться Слава Україні Слава
у по украї
по велику суть для усіх єдину наш гордий
Клич народові несе вітчизні бутьь Вій
вірний бе зупину нам
Україна вище понад все
причисні буть ти вірни бец упи на
Україна
Ще понад всея
[музика]
на
браття
украї
[оплески]
ся боя
нуть наші
Жені як роса на
сонці запанує
браття у свої
сторо душу і тіло
ми
набо і покажем
що ми браття
[оплески]
коза І дивно правда що на словах
Українського Гімну вийш ло сонце і
дійсно як в нашому гіні співається
згинуть наші вороженькі як роса на сонці
Вони думали що ми втечемо Вони думали що
ми розійдемося і вони просто тягнуть час
і думають що ну Наступного разу ніхто не
прийде ми будемо нескінченно переносити
це судилище і досягнемо результату ми їм
скажемо Ні тому що ми вийшли не тільки
за Петра Порошенка Ми вийшли за те щоб в
Україні не було цього свавілля
беззаконня і політичних
репресій Слава Україні Героям
слава сечас попробую
сга понад усе понад усе понад
[музика]
усева Я хочу
ще зараз
оголосити людей які вийдуть і виступлять
тут і підтримують Петра Порошенка це
представники міських рад українських
міст і зараз я надаю
[музика]
слово
Тернопільщина Привітайте будь
ласка голова обласної ради
Дорогі
українці Слава
Україні зовсім
недавно
позавчора на четвертому пленарному
засіданні Тернопільської обласної
ради
де одностайно депутатським корпусом
Тернопільської обласної ради було
підтримано звернення до Президента
України до Верховної Ради України до
Генеральної Прокуратури
України щодо
переслідування
опозиційних демократичних партій
учасників революції
гідності громадських
активістів за час який пройшов від
початку каденції шостого президента
України дозволяє нам Зробити висновки но
обрана влада на чолі з Володимиром
Зеленським стала на шлях четвертого
президента
України Віктора
Януковича який вже з перших днів свого
перебування на банковій
організвав широкі політичні
переслідування лідерів
опозиції президент України Володимир
Зеленський вже на першому році своєї
каденції і очолювана ним влада
організувала переслідування п'ятого
президента
України народного депутата України
лідера європейської солідарності Петра
Порошенка вже з перших днів нова влада
почала штампувати пачками кримінальні
провадження в чому їй самовіддано
допомагали соратники колишнього
президента Віктора Януковича а з
приходом на посаду Генерального
прокурора Ірини
венедиктової взагалі було поставлено
питання про арешту Порошенка і тільки
тиск наш з вами тиск
суспільства політичних діячів західної
Європи та інших країн змусили владу дати
вказівки генпрокурору
відпустити відступити від своїх намірів
проте ваханалія політичних переслідувань
продовжується і так можна сміливо додати
ще багато фактів політичних
переслідувань з боку чинної влади
справжніх патріотів України
це стосується і Софії федини і Марусі
зверобій і Тетяни
Чорновіл і ми депутати Тернопільської
обласної
ради вимагаємо від чинної влади на чолі
з президентом України Володимиром
Зеленським припинити політичні
переслідування зосередити свої зусилля
на протидії російській агресії активно
відстоювати національні інтереси України
на міжнародній арені і нарешті провадити
реальні реформи спрямовані на розвиток
української
держави і Дорогі українці особисто від
себе Я би хотів вас повернути події
шестирічної давності Коли у Росії
агресор вступила на українську землю
коли мільйони українців об'єдналися на
захист цієї української незалежної
держави від маленького до
великого обороняли Українську державу
пенсіонери віддавали останні заощадження
для того щоб зберегти цілісність нашої
держави ніхто навіть тоді подумки не міг
подумати що буде
переслідування патріотів України
переслідування добровольців волонтерів
військових А сьогодні ми тут
зібралися щоби не дати цьому реваншу не
дати сьогодні розчаруватися
українцям а об'єднатися не дати опустити
руки тому що за нами наші молоді
покоління сьогодні каденція шостого
президента може увійти у історію як роки
великого терору вам це нічого не нагадує
історію Столітньої давно
Української
держави Дорогі українці
заради того життя які віддали герої
Небесної Сотні заради тих добровольців
волонтерів і українських військових які
віддали своє життя за наше краще
майбутнє заради того щоби мрія їхня на
небесах була втілена жити у Віль
незалежній демократичній проєвропейській
українській
державі Слава Україні Героям
слава секретар Київської міської ради
Володимир
прокопєв такі Оплески ніби тут не тільки
регіони А ще є Київ є тут
Київ дороі друзі во 36 залі пленарних
засідань Київської міської
радизважаючи того що там представлено
багато різних партій але кожна фракція
Київської міської ради взяла участь в
голосуванні за звернення до президента
Зеленського де чітко
сказано те що
сьогодні тут відбувається немає жодного
відношення до
правосуддя Таким чином Столичний
парламент чітко і офіційно висловив свою
позицію ми вважаємо що депутати
міссцевих рад мають дбати за добробут
своїх містян кожен У своєму місці Але
коли в країні почалися політичні
репресії Київрада не може і не буде
мовчати Київ не може і не буде
мовчати Я хочу звернути увагу
центральної влади що місто Київ завжди
задавав тон у місцевому
самоврядуванні якщо інші місцеві ради
підхоплять таке звернення і підтримають
його ми з вами будемо жити в країні без
політичних репресій ми з вами
обов'язково переможемо Слава Україні
Героям
[оплески]
слава відео
Друзі будь ласка шах
[музика]
назад
Слава
Україні
два шага
[музика]
назад
Ну що ж друзі А я хочу щоб ви привітали
п'ятого президента України лідера
опозиції
Петра
порошен
Порошенко
три
гола
голамла
[музика]
ва ригова Кожен хоче подякувати Петру
Порошенко і потиснути
[оплески]
руку Соборна Україна одна єдина Соборна
Україна одна єдина свободна Україна
слава
Україні слава Слава нації дорогі
друзі Я ще раз дякую що в третій
раз десяток
тисяч людей приходить
підпечерський
приходить Щоби сказати рішуче ні
політичним реній
владі недосвідчених
стивих дрібних і
нехчени Зеленій владі яка організувала
світофорну зелену
хвилю російській п'ятій
[музика]
коло
всередині України
ге геглюге
ге
люгеге не тільки на банковий а і в
Чернівцях нехай чує Куди він сьогодні
сховався від
10да яка
бореться не з Росією не з окупантом а з
українськими волонтерами з українськими
добровольцями борються з Софією фдиною
борться з Марусю
звіробії порушили кримінальну справу
проти Володимира
вятровича бореться з нашими генералами
кіборгами на кшталт марченка
нічогіснько не здатні
запропонувати бореться
подивиться щойно
Кровавий наш
пастир
олексан
торчинов
очолив
[оплески]
штаб оплесками Привітайте
[музика]
[оплески]
торчинова усі адреси дбр яка
очолюється адвокатам і поплічником
Януковича направила запити про вилучення
документи і
обшуки для чого вони це
роблять я дивлюсь на десяток тисяч людей
на цьому майдані і в жодних Ваших очах я
не бачу
страху чи є тут ті хто налякані
ні
А хто у нас
Наляканий а вони самі раніше були
Софійка як вони називали потерпілі вони
були
потерпілі а сьогодні стали вже
паралізовані від
страху
[оплески]
паралізовані і вони свій час
присвячують тому щоби
запроторити українського позицію
заграти Ми хочемо
Нагадати в 13-му році один такий
був ми всі
ду дуже добре пам'ятаємо чим він
закінчив ворота на Ростов і квіток до
Ростову на
[оплески]
поготові Я Хочу наголосити
що за ці
злочини треба буде
відповідати ми їх не
боїмося вони Ти що сьогодні
вночі бо всі паскутні і дрібні справи
вони роблять вночі туд прийняв рішення
продовжити ще на ри
місяці за межами року коли закон
зобов'язає зобов'язує закінчити справу
продовжити ще на три місяці
розслідування справи про призначення
меною заступника керівника
[музика]
[оплески]
розв
сутті Печерського суду слухайте Цей
голос
народу вночі такі речі робити - це
злочин
під тиском такі речі робити це злочин і
тиснути це злочин для чого вони це
зробили
щоби витягти ще 15
млн грошей для цих злочинців з дбру з
коштів платників податків зробити для
того щоби
обмежити виборчу
кампанію бо наступного тижня будуть
оголошені вибори вибори які мають
відбутися в кінці жовтня і дуже Вони
хотіли би щоби Порошенко не мав
можливості Їздити по Україні дуже Вони
хотіли би щоби Порошенко не мав можли
їздити і захищати український інтерес по
світру Ми не
збираємося
виконуватичинні накази злочинної
[оплески]
влади бо ми є
єдина
українська
опозиція ви скажете що є ще одна
опозиція зж
Так але знаєте чим вона
[оплески]
відрізняєтьсяю вона є агентом держави
окупанта всередині нашої
держави і ми переможемо і вони будуть
відповідати і
я ідучи до суду дякуючи всіх вас дякуючи
мою родину дякуючи мою дружину яка в
найважчі хвилини
поруч Дякую моїх бойових
побратимів Дякую політичних в'язнів
героїв України Дякую волонтерів і
добровольців які тут зараз Дякую чесних
журналістів які висвітлюють і
демонструють Що зараз відбувається в
Україні я хочу запевнити вас уж хто хто
а Порошенко точно не здасться
безбою
[оплески]
дякую
друзі
Дякую вам я пішов на це судилище з вашою
підтримкою з вашою
допомогою
Ну що ж і поки наш лідер опозиції Петро
Порошенко пішов на це судилище я хочу
щоб ми згадали за що ж його судять а
судять його за ті речі які роблять
Україну Україною за Прості речі за армію
за мову і за віру Я хочу щоб ми згадали
що українську армію ми створювали разом
з вами фактично з
нуля Порошенко на своєму місці як
президент України ми громадяни своїми
податками і ми Волонтери польці які
боролися за
Україну і я хочу надати слово народному
герою України
волонтеру
[оплески]
[музика]
яніфнкевич ти сьогодні тут разом з
кожним з вас перед нами зараз стоїть
дуже велика загроза Ми прийшли до суду
щоб продемонструвати своє ставлення до
політичних репресій навіть
об їх одна і та ж юридична
у але українці не дозволять
переслідувати опозицію і я вдячна
кожному з вас заце шлях Зеленського
закінчиться у Ростові швидше ніж у
Яковича уже відбулась Революція Гідності
і Вони не зможуть забрати в нас цю
гідність бо ми знаємо що чекати від
авторитаризму авторитаризм не зупиниться
якщо його не зупинимо ми За останні
півроку я більше місяця провела на
судилищах по нашим ветеранам
волонтерам і активістам я розумію що
наступним може бути кожен з нас тому
сьогодні важливо боротись і
об'єднуватись щоб не втратити нашу
країну зараз
ідставні вимоги щодо запобіжного
за реакція міжнародної спільноти
підтримку Порошенка різкі заяви церкви і
автори Слава
Україні
Слава
або по захисту наших вояків
АТО або